have some breaking news Tessa
shareholders have approved a Solar City
merger by an eighty-five percent vote so
once again Tessa shareholders approving
that Solar City merger by eighty five
percent overwhelmingly the meeting is
taking place right now a lot of the
votes were already in about three
minutes ago but it was pretty clear how
quickly the vote took in terms of the
actual meeting you can also check it out
on live go so the chats our shareholder
meeting taking place right now on live
go on your Bloomberg in after-hours
trade Tesla Motors off by two percent
SolarCity bouncing around a little bit
unchanged Jim Chanos yesterday Joe was
saying that obviously he's not a fan of
Elon Musk Tesla or SolarCity but he was
saying that shareholders ought to have
their heads and he said that right I'm
not I thought he said that to it I
wondering if I was mr. Murdoch he said
they need to have their heads inspected
if they vote for this but eighty five
percent of the shares voted in favor of
it so there you go and there's Elon Musk
speaking which live on stage right now
at the Tesla shareholders meeting again
Elon Musk taking the stage here and he
certainly counts this as a success
because he had been pushing for this
merger a lot of people say that this is
a case of them being able to fund each
other it's a cash flow and part of it
you know for a while those lost
skepticism in the early weeks after was
announced there was a fairly big gap so
that's good news for him and you know
the other thing that chain owes
acknowledges that Elon Musk is a
fantastic story teller fantastic capital
razor so not surprising that the people
in Tesla who believe his vision and
believe his story are inclined to go
along with his vision of a combined
entities and on that news Tesla Motors
chairs down one percent in after-hours
trading this is Bloomberg